"The introduction of numbers as coordinates
is an act of violence."
—Hermann Weyl
The fundamental, root-of-it-all building block
for linear algebra is the vector, so it's
worth
making sure that we're all on the same page
about what exactly a vector is.
You see, broadly
speaking there are three distinct but related
ideas about vectors, which I'll call the physics
student perspective, the computer science
student perspective, and the mathematician's
perspective.
The physics student perspective is that vectors
are arrows pointing in space.
What defines a given
vector is its length, and the direction it's
pointing in, but as long as those two facts
are the
same, you can move it all around and it's
still the same vector.
Vectors that live in the flat plane
are two-dimensional, and those sitting in
broader space that you and I live in are three-dimensional.
The computer science perspective is that vectors
are ordered lists of numbers.
For example, let's
say that you were doing some analytics about
house prices, and the only features you cared
about
were square footage and price.
You might model each house with a pair of
numbers: the first
indicating square footage, and the second
indicating price.
Notice that the order matters here.
In the lingo, you'd be modelling houses as
two-dimensional vectors, where in this context,
"vector" is pretty much just a fancy word
for "list", and what makes it two-dimensional
is the fact
that the length of that list is 2.
The mathematician, on the other hand, seeks
to generalise both of these views, basically
saying that
a vector can be anything where there's a sensible
notion of adding two vectors, and multiplying
a
vector by a number, operations that I'll talk
about later on in this video.
The details of this view
are rather abstract, and I actually think
it's healthy to ignore it until the last video
of this
series, favoring a more concrete setting in
the interim,
but the reason that I bring it up here is
that it hints at the fact that ideas of vector
addition
and multiplication by numbers will play an
important role throughout linear algebra.
But before I talk about those operations,
let's just settle in on a specific thought
to have in mind
when I say the word "vector".
Given the geometric focus that I'm shooting
for here, whenever I
introduce a new topic involving vectors, I
want you to first think about an arrow—and
specifically,
think about that arrow inside a coordinate
system, like the x-y plane, with its tail
sitting at the origin.
This is a little bit different from the physics
student perspective, where vectors can freely
sit
anywhere they want in space.
In linear algebra, it's almost always the
case that your vector will be
rooted at the origin.
Then, once you understand a new concept in
the context of arrows in space,
we'll translate it over to the list-of-numbers
point-of-view, which we can do by considering
the coordinates of the vector.
Now while I'm sure that many of you are familiar
with this coordinate system, it's worth walking
through explicitly, since this is where all
of the important back-and-forth happens between
the two
perspectives of linear algebra.
Focusing our attention on two dimensions for
the moment, you have a
horizontal line, called the x-axis, and a
vertical line, called the y-axis.
The place where they
intersect is called the origin, which you
should think of as the center of space and
the root of all vectors.
After choosing an arbitrary length to represent
1, you make tick-marks on each axis to
represent this distance.
When I want to convey the idea of 2-D space
as a whole, which you'll see
comes up a lot in these videos, I'll extend
these tick-marks to make grid-lines, but right
now
they'll actually get a little bit in the way.
The coordinates of a vector is a pair of numbers
that
basically give instructions for how to get
from the tail of that vector—at the origin—to
its tip.
The first number tells you how far to walk
along the x-axis—positive numbers indicating
rightward
motion, negative numbers indicating leftward
motion—and the second number tell you how
far to walk
parallel to the y-axis after that—positive
numbers indicating upward motion, and negative
numbers
indicating downward motion.
To distinguish vectors from points, the convention
is to write this pair
of numbers vertically with square brackets
around them.
Every pair of numbers gives you one and only
one vector, and every vector is associated
with one and
only one pair of numbers.
What about in three dimensions?
Well, you add a third axis, called the z-axis,
which is perpendicular to both the x- and
y-axes, and in this case each vector is associated
with an ordered triplet of numbers: the first
tells you how far to move along the x-axis,
the second
tells you how far to move parallel to the
y-axis, and the third one tells you how far
to then move
parallel to this new z-axis.
Every triplet of numbers gives you one unique
vector in space, and
every vector in space gives you exactly one
triplet of numbers.
So back to vector addition, and multiplication
by numbers.
After all, every topic in linear algebra
is going to center around these two operations.
Luckily, each one is pretty straightforward
to define.
Let's say we have two vectors, one pointing
up, and a little to the right, and the other
one
pointing right, and down a bit.
To add these two vectors, move the second
one so that its tail sits
at the tip of the first one; then if you draw
a new vector from the tail of the first one
to where
the tip of the second one now sits, that new
vector is their sum.
This definition of addition, by the way, is
pretty much the only time in linear algebra
where we let
vectors stray away from the origin.
Now why is this a reasonable thing to do?—Why
this definition of addition and not some other
one?
Well the way I like to think about it is that
each vector represents a certain movement—a
step with
a certain distance and direction in space.
If you take a step along the first vector,
then take a step in the direction and distance
described by the second vector, the overall
effect is
just the same as if you moved along the sum
of those two vectors to start with.
You could think about this as an extension
of how we think about adding numbers on a
number line.
One way that we teach kids to think about
this, say with 2+5, is to think of moving
2 steps to the
right, followed by another 5 steps to the
right.
The overall effect is the same as if you just
took
7 steps to the right.
In fact, let's see how vector addition looks
numerically.
The first vector
here has coordinates (1,2), and the second
one has coordinates (3,-1).
When you take the vector sum
using this tip-to-tail method, you can think
of a four-step path from the origin to the
tip of the
second vector: "walk 1 to the right, then
2 up, then 3 to the right, then 1 down."
Re-organising
these steps so that you first do all of the
rightward motion, then do all of the vertical
motion,
you can read it as saying, "first move 1+3
to the right, then move 2+(-1) up," so the
new vector has
coordinates 1+3 and 2+(-1).
In general, vector addition in this list-of-numbers
conception looks
like matching up their terms, and adding each
one together.
The other fundamental vector operation is
multiplication by a number.
Now this is best understood
just by looking at a few examples.
If you take the number 2, and multiply it
by a given vector, it
means you stretch out that vector so that
it's 2 times as long as when you started.
If you multiply
that vector by, say, 1/3, it means you squish
it down so that it's 1/3 of the original length.
When you multiply it by a negative number,
like -1.8, then the vector first gets flipped
around,
then stretched out by that factor of 1.8.
This process of stretching or squishing or
sometimes reversing the direction of a vector
is called "scaling",
and whenever you catch a number like 2 or
1/3 or -1.8 acting like this—scaling some
vector—you call it a "scalar".
In fact, throughout linear algebra, one of
the main things that
numbers do is scale vectors, so it's common
to use the word "scalar" pretty much interchangeably
with the word "number".
Numerically, stretching out a vector by a
factor of, say, 2, corresponds to
multiplying each of its components by that
factor, 2, so in the conception of vectors
as
lists of numbers, multiplying a given vector
by a scalar means multiplying each one of
those components by that scalar.
You'll see in the following videos what I
mean when I say that linear algebra topics
tend to revolve
around these two fundamental operations: vector
addition, and scalar multiplication; and I'll
talk
more in the last video about how and why the
mathematician thinks only about these operations,
independent and abstracted away from however
you choose to represent vectors.
In truth, it doesn't
matter whether you think about vectors as
fundamentally being arrows in space—like
I'm suggesting
you do—that happen to have a nice numerical
representation, or fundamentally as lists
of numbers
that happen to have a nice geometric interpretation.
The usefulness of linear algebra has less
to do with
either one of these views than it does with
the ability to translate back and forth between
them.
It gives the data analyst a nice way to conceptualise
many lists of numbers in a visual way,
which can seriously clarify patterns in data,
and give a global view of what certain operations
do,
and on the flip side, it gives people like
physicists and computer graphics programmers
a language
to describe space and the manipulation of
space using numbers that can be crunched and
run through a computer.
When I do math-y animations, for example,
I start by thinking about what's actually
going on in
space, and then get the computer to represent
things numerically, thereby figuring out where
to
place the pixels on the screen, and doing
that usually relies on a lot of linear algebra
understanding.
So there are your vector basics, and in the
next video I'll start getting into some pretty
neat
concepts surrounding vectors, like span, bases,
and linear dependence.
See you then!
Captioned by Navjivan Pal